hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast liquid chromatography
tandem mass spectrometry research in
testosterone analysis considerations of
instrument performance versus sample
preparation complexity presented by dr.
Joshua Hayden assistant professor of
pathology and Laboratory Medicine at
Weill Cornell Medical College
I'm Cindy Valdez of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning and it's made possible today by
our sponsor agilent technologies agilent
is a leader in life sciences diagnostics
and applied chemical markets the cuppa
tea provides laboratories worldwide with
instruments services consumables
applications and expertise enabling
customers to gain the insight they seek
Agilent expertise and trusted
collaboration gives customers the
highest confidence in the company's
solution for more information about our
sponsor visit their site at wwe.com
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on that green Q&A button located
at the lower left of your presentation
window and type your questions into the
box that appear on the screen well
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
notice that you're viewing this
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window and use that Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem good news this educational
presentation is offering education
credits please click on the button in
the bottom left hand corner and follow
the process to obtain those credits
please join me now in welcoming dr.
Joshua Hayden I will now turn the
presentation over to him well
I'm dr. Hayden thank you very much for
the injection and thank you everyone for
joining us as mentioned we are going to
be talking today about this molecule
here called testosterone and how we
measure it why we need to measure it and
some different approaches to consider
I'm sure many of you in the research and
non research setting might already be
measuring testosterone so I wanted to
start with a quick poll question just to
figure out how is everybody
measuring testosterone as you can see
are you performing by GCMs maybe LCMS no
you're not performing any testosterone
testing by mass spectrometry we complain
to in the future or no I'm not currently
doing mass spectrometry based
measurements testosterone in lab and I
have no plans to in the future
I always think it's helpful to start
with a poll question so I can see who
all is is awakened and paying attention
right so what are some of the reasons
that we might want to be measuring mass
for testosterone by mass spectrometry
you might have noticed on my first slide
next to the testosterone was a figure
showing deaths from cancer in United
States and males and prostate cancer
ranked number two with a little over
26,000 deaths annually over 160,000 new
cases per year and statistics show that
about one in seven men will be diagnosed
with prostate cancer during their
lifetime
now primarily this is going to be older
individuals with 60% of them or more
being diagnosed over 65 and so there's a
real need to understand when and how to
treat prostate cancer especially given
the morbidities associated with the
treatment and the age of individuals
suffering from it one treatment option
which has come about is androgen
deprivation therapy which is illustrated
here this is reproduced from recent
nature review and urology the idea is
relatively straightforward so
intracellular androgen concentrations
that's going to be testosterone and
dihydrotestosterone are known to drive
prostate cancer growth through
interactions with the androgen receptor
and subsequent downstream interactions
so the goal here is to start to lower
the androgen levels in an effort to stop
or slow tumor growth now there are
multiple pathways to reducing androgen
levels one of the first and most
prevalent would be luteinizing hormone
releasing hormone agnus which are going
to stop systemic production of the
androgens I should point point out here
that the majority of the androgens are
going to be synthesized by the testes
but they can also be produced by the
adrenal glands even if we start to
inhibit this we can still have
production of
engines within cells and so we have
developed inhibitors of 17 which can
actually inhibit the intracellular
synthesis I should mention that
inhibiting intracellular synthesis we
care the most about the
dihydrotestosterone
so while testosterone is most commonly
measured because it's a great systemic
source of the dihydrotestosterone the
most active is actually the
dihydrotestosterone this is very similar
to how we generally are going to measure
t4 even though within the cells c3 is
far more active now there are newer ways
to block downstream elements such as
androgen receptor antagonists as shown
there and then there are more extreme
androgen deprivation therapy switch
involved triple androgen blockade and
have the inclusion of 5 alpha reductase
inhibitors to prevent that intracellular
conversion of testosterone to
dihydrotestosterone now all of these
therapies are going to carry substantial
negative sequelae
and so the questions which persists are
who do we have to treat when do we treat
how do we treat how long to continue
treating obviously our goal here is
improving morbidity mortality from these
treatments and how do we know if we're
actually doing that how are we measuring
response to these treatments and
improvement in morbidity mortality there
were some early suggestions that lower
systemic testosterone levels following
androgen deprivation therapy pretended
lower mortality with sub castrate levels
that being testosterone below 20
nanograms per deciliter or 0.7 nanomoles
per liter for those more comfortable
with those units was actually superior
to the super castrate levels that would
be disaster own levels around 50
nanograms per deciliter or 1.7 in
animals per liter the strongest data for
this actually came from
study shown here where they had 626 men
with a median follow-up of eight years
and they wanted to see how the death
hazard ratio changed relative to the
Nader levels of testosterone Nader level
being the lowest level of achieved
response and you can see in the curves
if the individuals reached a nadir
testosterone 20 nanograms per deciliter
or less the hazard ratio was one if the
testosterone only went down to 49
nanograms per deciliter or greater the
hazard ratio was almost three it's
important to point point out that this
was observational right they found lower
testosterone was corresponding with
lower mortality they did not investigate
whether intervening to actively lower
testosterone actually lowered mortality
so a lot of questions still persist
further research is needed not the least
of which is this question of whether
it's systemic testosterone levels or
intramural desk toss current levels and
how are we actually even supposed to be
testing these low levels now that one is
especially of interest to me as a
clinical chemist I find myself often
most interested with how we measure
things so what are our options for
measuring dust ah Cerrone well the most
commonly use will be direct testosterone
and you know assays so I'm showing some
data here from my lab where you can see
on the x-axis is results from a tandem
mass spectrometry based measurement of
testosterone and on the y-axis is
results from an immunoassay I should
mention this is a commercially available
direct immunity but it's one which is
fairly well vetted this is not an
off-the-shelf iliza this is the type of
amino acid be used in many clinical labs
across the country and notice below 40
nanograms per deciliter we really have
this cloud of data and I'm highlighting
in the red circle if we look at a person
with a testosterone level by this amino
acid
or by the mass spec who has in a
testosterone below 20 nanograms per
deciliter what is their true
testosterone and what is the hazard
ratios this patient right is it one or
is it three and you can tell that a
testosterone level down below 10 by mass
spec could be as high as 50 by this
immunoassay now I'm not just
cherry-picking one really bad direct
immunoassay the same criticism could be
levelled on a range of immunoassays in
use so this is data taken out of 2003 a
clinical chemistry paper this was used
with permission from a SEC and we can
see the performance of for commercial
direct communal assays versus mass
spectrometry in this case is the isotope
dilution gas chromatography mass
spectrometry on the x-axis is going to
be the true testosterone level in this
case in animals per liter and on the
y-axis we're going to have the ratio so
that would be the result from the
indicated immunoassay divided by the
result from the mass spec so a ratio of
1 would indicate excellent agreement the
farther from 1 the greater the
discrepancy and you can see for a large
number of men the filled in black
circles we have relatively good
agreement with ratios around 1 however
as you get to the female population so
this would be the open circles with
levels down below 10 nanomoles per liter
or below 280 some nanograms per
deciliter you can see that the ratios
changed substantially right
and so those ratios in general are going
to be biased you can see some bias high
up to three over four full difference
while some 4:1 immunoassay you know SI 3
for instance will also have some
negative bias so this isn't a universal
bias that we can just adjust our values
and this work led to this really nice
publication
be thorough Rob Fitzgerald which talked
about whether or not these amino acids
are actually any better than just a
random guess right and you'll notice one
of the immunoassays I've chosen here is
the ACS 180 this is notable because it's
been used as the predicate method for
all but one fda-approved direct
testosterone immunoassay that I know of
so this isn't standard by which many
assays in the clinical lab are actually
held to and that's a problem you also
know the terrible performance of all
these assays in the female patient
population it's not just men with
prostate cancer undergoing androgen
deprivation therapy where we care about
accurate low-level testosterone right
these accurate low-level measurements
are important in women especially as
part of the workup for polycystic ovary
syndrome as well as for children who
generally fall into these low
testosterone measures and accurate
quantitation is important in cases of
precocious or delayed puberty
unexplained variation and newborns with
ambiguous genitalia all of these
situations are going to represent
scenarios in which accurate low level
testosterone measures are important and
we know these are important we also know
that they can be inaccurate at these low
levels right so what are we going to do
about this so this brings up another
polling question I had just because I'm
always curious to see how individuals
deal with this in their labs so will
your laboratory report low level
testosteron results but say below 50
nanograms per deciliter from a direct
immunoassay and there are options Jim
yes yes but maybe you append a comment
stating the limitation of those low
levels yes but maybe you differentiate
between women and children and won't
report for certain genders or ages or no
my lab simply will not report direct
disaster and immunity results below 50
nanograms per deciliter
so as you think about this it's it's
worth pointing out that a number of
others are thinking about how we address
these inaccuracies at the low level so
fortunately The Endocrine Society has
actually come out with some very clear
guidelines so this is taking an excerpt
from their position statement in 2007
where they comment that the technology
exists to perform accurate precise
reproducible assays for testosterone and
assays after extraction chromatography
followed either by a master immunoassay
are likely to furnish more reliable
results and are preferred right there's
a few things about this statement that I
really like the first is that comment
that the technology exists which always
has me thinking about that six million
dollar man opening where they say we can
rebuild them we have the technology or
however that goes right but it's an
important statement because what we're
addressing here is not an intractable
problem it is possible for laboratories
to report accurate precise reproducible
testosterone levels even at these low
levels right and the first part is to
start avoiding these inaccurate assays
that perform so poorly such as in women
children ipogo nate'll men he also
noticed that you can use either the MS
or the immunoassay following the
extraction so radio immunoassays have
been shown to work incredibly well now
not many of us are going to want to use
radio immunoassays right that's another
one of the reasons mass spec has become
so popular now this position statement
is geared at patient care right but
there's a very important question asked
which is how can we use these
poor-performing assays in the research
setting how can we expect to obtain
meaningful results that can be
translated into clinical practice if we
use inaccurate amino acids and the
reality is you can't in the endocrine
society recognizes that 2013 they
published a statement on steroid
measurements and
chronology research stating that
effective January 2015
any manuscript would choose sex steroid
assays such as for testosterone as
important endpoints have to use ms/ms
based methods including reporting and
citing their methods with the sufficient
detail to allow reproduction right this
is really great advance I think getting
clinical societies and research
societies thinking about where their
numbers are coming from and whether or
not these are numbers that can be
trusted so now with these guidelines in
place what are we as laboratory ins
supposed to do well by a mass
spectrometer obviously right good time
to remind you that that this is
sponsored by Agilent and then total
operators are standing by
so please call now now all joking aside
I should mention that you'll be hearing
a lot about my labs experience using
Agilent instruments for testosterone
it's what we use it's what we know
there's lots of other great platforms
out there that exist but whenever you're
investigating these platforms you want
to try to think about what you need your
instrument to do and you'll really
define the problem I think a good first
step is just looking at the assay you
want to develop what are their
requirements what are the challenges
so let's unravel this a bit for
testosterone so testosterone as shown
here
is the primary male sex hormone it's a
Kanata corticoid organ and a steroid the
core structure is 17 carbons fused into
four rings which you can see labeled a b
c d now testosteron in particular it's
going to have this ketone on the third
carbon a double bond between carbons
four and five and then a hydroxyl group
on carbon 17 overall this is not a very
polar compound and it's going to
circulate almost entirely protein bound
within the body
with only 2% or so three the majority is
going to be tightly bound to a low
abundance protein sex hormone-binding
globulin with weaker binding to the far
more abundant albumin also accounting
for a large fraction so when we talk
about testosterone we can be talking
about total testosterone which is going
to be in the range of ten to a thousand
we can talk about bioavailable
testosterone which is going to be the
free testosterone plus the albumin bound
portion and we can talk about just free
testosterone which is going to be in
that 0.2 to 20 nanogram per deciliter
range obviously what we're trying to
measure is going to dictate what we need
out of our instruments I'll be focusing
primarily on the total testosterone
today I'll also mention that there are
ways that you can calculate the free
testosterone using accurate total
testosterone measurements and accurate
measurements of sex hormone binding
globulin and albumin so if we're going
to be doing this by mass spectrometry we
want to be thinking about some of our
gotchas ahead of time right what are
some of the pitfalls we're going to need
to worry about since we're using MS
based methods one of the big ones we
need to worry about our isobaric
interferences so with testosterone there
are two very important ones to be aware
of so the one will be DHEA which in the
sulfated form is going to be present in
serum concentrations orders of magnitude
above testosterone and you can see that
th EI is a structural isomer with the
same formula as sauce around just
slightly different arrangement of the
atoms
however the atom arrangement is really
only slightly different so it's
something you're going to want to be
aware of when you're developing your
chromatographic method you're going to
want to make sure you're getting good
separation here in addition to this
structural isomer there's also stereo
isomer this will be the EPI testosterone
here the only difference is the hydroxyl
group on carbon 17
is in a different configuration this is
very similar to 25 hydroxy vitamin D
which has an epimer and non of America
form and just like in 25 hydroxy our
goal is accurate measurement of the non
epimer form now certainly measurement of
total testosterone and the epimer are
important other applications sports
still being USA DEA would care very much
about this it's not something I'm going
to spend much time talking about there
in addition to these biological bars
there are some other concerns that you
want to be aware of before embarking on
this sort of assay so there's isobars
just from the gel tubes what I'm showing
here is a plasma separator - or tube or
PSC but we see similar results from SSDs
where if you let serum or plasma sit on
top of that gel and then you analyze it
what you're looking at is a chromatogram
for a sample that contains about 10
nanograms per deciliter testosterone and
that's labeled with the star and little
red TE above it and those giant Peaks
which dwarf that symbol are all isobaric
interferences from those gels right so
whenever you're going to let samples
sort of do on these thixotropic
polymeric gels it's something you want
to think carefully about before
injecting that on your instrument these
gel tubes are an array of chemicals
viscous liquids organics inorganic
fillers
PACA fires all of which have the
possibility to interfere with sample
analysis how you choose to deal with
this whether it's through clear
separation of the interferences of the
chromatography just not allowing gel
tubes in your lab that's certainly your
choice but it's definitely an issue that
has to be dealt with and these are some
of those major interferences we're going
to want to think about so what are other
analytic requirements of our
testosterone si so fortunately a lot of
great work has already gone into
standardizing testosterone measurements
there were clearly defined
performance criteria from the CDC as
part of their hormone standardization
program or the host program right this
is all supported by information of the
partnership for accurate testing of
hormones led by an Akron Society with
collaboration of NIH FDA and CDC and
what the CDC has said in collaboration
with them is that performance criterion
will be plus or minus 6.4 percent mean
bias relative to the CDC testosterone
reference method which is an LC ms/ms
method and you want to be able to go
over the concentration range of 2.5 to
1,000 nanograms per deciliter
now the certification will happen in two
phases a first step is what they termed
calibration here you can receive 40
serum samples with reference value
assignments the examples could be non
polled single donor sera from male and
female donors and they help you assess
the accuracy of your test as well as
adjusting your calibration if necessary
once you feel comfortable in your method
then you're able to move on to phase 2
which is the method bias assessment here
you will have for quarterly challenges
each containing 10 blind samples which
you'll run the unknown serum samples for
analysis and report the values and then
the CDC will assess your bias if you
fall within the plus or minus 6.4
percent then you get listed on the
website okay now these sorts of
standardization endeavors are a
tremendous amount of work and they're
also tremendously helpful in the field
and I would say as a clinical chemist
any time I know that there is one of
these standardization programs I always
feel like that is the standard I should
try to to hold myself to and so I would
definitely advocate anybody thinking
about developing a mass spectrometry
based assay for testosterone should
consider standardization in the CDC host
program if you're not going to you can
also just get the phase 1 calibration
samples so that you can have a good
sense how your method is performing
because there's a number of factors that
can affect it which were
not going to have a chance to talk about
in this webinar so important factors
would include your internal standard
choice we make this assumption that
everywhere our analyte goes and
everything happens to the analyte all
right internal standard goes and happens
to that and it's just not always the
case for testosterone in particular
deuterated testosterone can have some
stability and issues so kind of
take-home message would definitely be to
go with a carbon-13 of three mass unit
difference
I assure you even though you might look
at the initial cost over the life span
of your assay it's really pennies the
next major issue is going to be
calibration so all the best method
development in the world is only going
to help you ensure accurate signal
response and it's your calibration curve
that converts that signal response into
a concentration which means best method
in the world with an inaccurate
calibration curve gives inaccurate
methods some good pointers here try to
use matrix match calibrators organic
solvent is not appropriate for
calibrator if you're doing a CRM based
measurement and also you're going to
want to whenever possible try to let
someone else do the QC right work right
so if you can find something
commercially available which
approximates your matrix not always easy
given that endogenous compounds like
testosterone are going to be in any
serum but there are options for this so
now we know what kind of assay we're
trying to develop right what's our next
step so the next step is defining what
you need from your instrument right so
let's say we decide that we want
accurate masks excellent quantitation
over a broad dynamic range which works
equally well for small and large
molecules it needs to be robust low-cost
and ideally it makes us coffee in the
morning right so now we have defined
what we want the next obvious step
compromise right it's like I always tell
my wife she knows exactly what she wants
but then she settled for me and that's
just how life goes sometimes there is no
perfect
instruments now there are instruments
that can make our lives more or less
enjoyable and what do I mean by
enjoyable enjoyable I mean an instrument
that facilitates robust analysis to help
us meet the desire to analytic
specifications of our assay and in
theory this should be relatively easy
right mass spectrometers make ions and
measure ions all we need is for it to
make testosterone ion and measure that
ion right it should be a match made in
heaven unfortunately that's not really
the case right there's a lot of steps
and biceps I mean an obstacle course
between your compound and serum to it
becoming an ion and from that ion
actually reaching your detector and
generating response they think of this
obstacle course like the pyramid from
American Gladiators or if you're a
little younger maybe something out of
ninja warrior' right so when I talk
about a better instrument I'm talking
about an instrument that helps these
ions overcome this obstacle course so
getting a little more scientific right
this is a schematic I took of a triple
quadrupole right you can see from LC
exit to detector I have to say too often
when I would show a mass spectrometer
schematic it would basically just be a
couple quadruples with some sort of
approximated collision cell in the
middle and more than anything this
webinar was me wanting to understand all
those other pieces in a mass
spectrometer and how they impact the
sensitivity of our instruments because
as it turns out there's been a lot of
changes in advances in many of those non
triple quadrupole steps such as the ion
optics the octuple guide sampling etc
which I hope to better understand and
maybe try to mention to you here once
again I'm talking about the instruments
I know many vendors have seen great
improvements and it's really good to be
speaking with them about what
improvements went into it right because
the reality is that every ion you want
that's lost by your instrument
Plus every eye and you don't want that
gets through that equals sample prep and
that's really what we're coming down to
you here this is the trade-off that
we're always facing with a better
instrument we can sometimes let
ourselves get a little lazy on sample
prep elephant in the room sometimes the
sample prep is not about achieving
analyticals but ensuring robust
instrument performance over the course
of thousands of injections right dirty
samples kill instruments and ultimately
caused that instrument downtime and
longevity issues right still in many
instances we need to do sample prep
above and beyond what needs to keep our
instruments clean just so that we can
accomplish the required analysis on that
instrument right a simple solid phase
extraction would be great for 125
dihydroxy vitamin D nobody wants to do
amino acid extraction and pthe
derivatives asian but they do it because
the instrument doesn't have necessary
sensitivity to meet the goal without it
and that's our trade-off right
and of course when we're talking about
the sample prep right we're talking
about literally a cost so time is FTE
and FTE is the biggest cost in most of
our labs right so it's sort of this
question of what do you want to spend
your money on instrument or prep so what
does it take an exam two examples from
methods which I've seen use one on a
sixty four sixty and another in my own
lab on a higher level more sensitive
triple quad six four ninety five right
let's take a hypothetical situation
where our lab is running let's say two
runs a week full 96-well plates each run
right I really think these two methods
here are going to highlight the
trade-off between sample prep and
instrument now this is not to say that
the 64 60 doesn't itself have some
advantages that help be ions go through
the obstacle course but I think you'll
see some of the improvements which can
come with the higher level instrument
now in both of these methods I will be
talking about utilizing electrospray
ionisation
right so we're all probably sick of
seeing this yes I figure right but I
think it deserves talking about a bit
because it highlights some points first
I have to mention that ESI is probably
not the best choice for testosterone ESI
is generally going to need some sort of
hetero atom to actually generate the
ions which is an easy on that very
hydrophobic steroid structure a PCI is
likely a much better choice but it's not
something I have much experience with so
I'm sort of sticking with the devil I
know so to speak right also there are
things we can do to help with the
ionization right so how does
electrospray ionisation work we all sort
of notice our stream of fluid comes out
of the LC through charged capillary
nebulizer gas on the outside it forms
that Taylor cone aerosol plume sort of
just like your your can of hairspray and
now those charged molecules and the
droplets start to repel each other as
the droplet shrinks and gets evaporated
you get the Rowley limit columbic
explosions and ultimately what you're
trying to do is generate these gas phase
ions which can be sucked into your
instrument but this really is an
oversimplification of the process and in
particular some of the options that our
analytes have leaving the LC right as
your analyte is leaving the LC it can
just precipitate as a solid or CO solid
right and aiko solid I mean other things
coming off the column with your sample
can cause loss of the intensity or
perhaps your analyte can stay in liquid
and just spray all over the interface of
your MS right it could go into the gas
phase but go in uncharged despite your
best efforts to charge it then it
becomes a neutral and it makes your life
even more challenging even if it goes in
to gas as an ion or an ion cluster right
then you can have the charge be
neutralized or charged stripped and
either way you don't end up with a
charged compound in the gas phase
reaching your ms the data i've seen has
suggested that it's something like one
out of every ten to the fourth
ion's which actually hit the detector
right so what can we do we want to make
as many ions as possible right so we can
improve our chances here testosterone
will generally be working in in positive
mode setting some formic acid ammonium
formate can help also as we have a
higher organic concentration that can
lead to smaller droplet size which means
there's more likely to form ions and
this rate of ion formation is going to
be increased by the concentration of the
ions and decreased by increasing droplet
size right so there's been some advances
on ESI look at one of them which is in
use on the 64 sixty right so this is a
jet stream so this is doing what I think
almost every manufacturer is doing where
nobody is spraying directly into the MS
source right we all recognize now the
importance of this sort of orthogonal
spray right and so there have been a few
improvements which go into the jet
stream to actually try to improve the
number of ions going into the MS one
will be increasing I information and the
second would be increasing the ion
transmission decreasing the unwanted
right so to increase the I information
they have this stream of superheated
chief gas which is going to go through
around that chart to capillary no that's
going to do is actually culminate the
nebulizer spray and create this narrower
spray which is going to concentrate our
ions also the superheated chief gas is
also going to help improve D salvation
so now we have this higher iron
concentration smaller droplet size so
increased ionization efficiency and then
we can position a capillary at the prime
spot in that stream where we can sample
and try to suck in the desired ions with
the heated drying gas gun on the outside
to hopefully keep out the neutrals
and looking at this in pictures just
because it's fun that they can put a
camera in a mass spectrometer you can
see the green would be the size of the
plume without the jet stream the orange
is going to be the size of the plume
with the jet stream and you can see the
capillary right there sampling off of it
now this has been shown to increase the
sensitivity although this is a good time
to mention that it's very hard to get
accurate instrument to instrument
comparisons right because different
instruments can perform differently for
different compounds different sample
types different conditions etc so very
hard to compare between manufacturers
however certainly within a manufacturer
sometimes you can get a better sense of
how they've improved that next model and
that's what you're seeing with clear
intent ago there on the chart for with
and without the jet stream alright so
what can we do with an instrument like
this so this is a testosterone method
which was developed and put in use by
folks out at peace health labs this was
obviously a little while ago was
presented in 2014 the details were share
with me by Seafarer forth I think it's a
very nice method and something I wanted
to to look into from my own lab so they
used this three-step sample prep where
they do a protein crash followed by
solid phase extraction using the bandha
loop LexA they loot with methyl
tert-butyl ether and then they're going
to derivatives with hydroxyl amine
before Risa spending in mobile phase and
injecting and here they will quantify on
the derivatives test oh as shown with
the quant and qual overall good
chromatography a three minute runtime
you can look at the validation data from
their 2014 ACC poster and you can see
overall strong performance now one of
the things I like about this and it's
very important is you can see then
narrow analytic range right there
showing from 0 to 100 and that's very
important this also has a wide dynamic
and most method taking the direct amino
acids will do well as you go over 500 or
so and that can really kind of skew your
correlation so it looks better than it
is so if you are looking at developing
testosterone si definitely make sure
that you're separating to look at both
the above and the below let's say 100
nanograms per deciliter to really get a
sense of how it's performing so what's
contributing to the strong performance
of this method well so we have the
protein precipitation with the zinc
sulfate and the methanol will actually
break up the testosterone from
testosterone binding proteins whether
sex hormone binding globulin or albumin
and then we have the SPE now in this
case they're using a bond dilute so says
this hydrophilic outer hydrophobic inner
that can help to trap some of the
hydrophobic analytes so you big things
like proteins and other such
interferences are gonna go to wash out
right so what are the interferences that
we really care about in mass
spectrometry so certainly proteins are
one we could say isobars except you're
really unlikely to separate out your
isobars using a solid phase extraction
you have to rely on your analytical
column for that right one of the big
interferences so to improve sensitivity
will be the phospholipids right these
are going to be the second highest lipid
content in blood after triglycerides
you're looking at about a milligram per
mil in concentration whereas
testosterone is going to be more like
0.1 nanograms per mil right they can be
especially problematic when you're doing
positive mode ionization due to the ion
suppression and they can be really hard
to remove these phospholipids are gonna
have this large lipid tail they can drag
them along with hydrophobic interaction
chemistry's and the sweater ionic head
can make even ion exchange really
challenging right now the same thing can
be said for liquid liquid extraction of
course where they're also going to be
extracted with almost anything certainly
one of the advantages of solid phase
extraction is that we had this very wide
range of chemistry's which are actually
possible and allow us to optimize our
method for best recovery
sample it's also automatable although
keep in mind that anytime you want to
automate it that involves an additional
expense some of the disadvantages the
increased complexity of the workflow
it's more labor-intensive and there is a
cost right so if we're looking at about
$2 a sample for the SPE supplies in our
hypothetical lab of 2 96-well plates a
week you're looking at about $20,000 a
year
100k over the course of five years so
any reasonable expense if you're doing
it to prevent instrument downtime and
keep your instruments clean but
definitely an added expense when you're
thinking about what is required for each
method I'm also finding that solid-phase
extraction just isn't something a lot of
people like to do or have experience
with so just a quick poll right do you
perform solid-phase extraction in your
lab yes some of you do it manually maybe
yes maybe some of you automated it yes
and you wish you didn't or just know
you're not doing solid phase reaction so
in my own lab we do do some solid phase
extraction but I have to admit I'm not a
huge fan of it it can however help with
keeping your hands clean and sensitivity
another thing that can help with
sensitivity is good to be the derivative
a shin right so this method on six 460
uses of the oxime derivatives asian
right this is going to work through a
variety of mechanisms the first is just
making a non ILS non ionizable sample
more ionizable yeah so this oxime
derivatives testosterone can pick up
charge better than the non-derivative
Saucer the same way we same reason we do
the PPA derivatives Asian or 125 right
so we increase the likelihood of
generating a charged analyte in the gas
phase independent of what's going on at
our instrument right it can also help
with our chromatography right so so we
know that we have these these zones
of inhibition or zones violence
oppression I superimpose the
testosterone and the oxime testosterone
from the Tom Ansley paper but that
Ansley paper is a nice look at sort of
these uh science oppression studies you
know maybe what we're doing is shifting
our compound out of that region where
you're having interference certainly
also Jun boxing derivatives ation it's
going to come out a little sooner on
your reverse ace column you can have
faster chromatography and furthermore it
lets you do a c18 SPE and a c18
analytical phase which you wouldn't
generally do because you want to use
orthogonal chemistry's except in this
cases we've derivatives we can still
benefit from it right so all this looks
looks great and it works quite well but
what could we do with a slightly higher
level triple quad something like the
6495 and what actually goes in goes into
that instrument to make it quote unquote
higher sensitivity right so let's just
remember the ion obstacle course that we
want so somehow our quote unquote better
instrument needs to get more of those
ions we're losing or prevent those ions
we don't want from getting through in
order for us to be able to reduce sample
prep so the the 6495 is is going to use
that same jet stream functionality
however in this case what they realize
is that while we're sort of trying to
get sampling at that sweet spot we're
still missing a lot right so one of the
improvements was the introduction of
this hexa board capillary which just
like it sounds like is six capillaries
now I strongly advocated that they have
11 capillaries but they told me they
can't do that so I guess I've been
watching too much spinal tap but you
know it's it's actually interesting to
me because I would have thought that
just a larger capillary would do a
better job sampling it's probably why
they don't let me divine design mass
spectrometers right because as I'm told
this larger capillary actually doesn't
accomplish
you get some some turbulent flow issues
and things like that however having
these these six capillaries all around
it does allow for much greater sampling
of ions so we're getting more ions from
the from the stream into the MS however
we're also getting a lot of other things
right so a lot more gas and this is
going to cause a problem later on and so
how do we how do we deal with this so
the way you can deal with this in this
495 is the next step is they have this
dual ion funnel so our little ion is
going to take its path from its jet
stream get sucked into one of those six
x''b or capillaries get guided down into
this high-pressure funnel and you'll
note that the entrance from the axial or
capillary to the high-pressure funnel
and the entran or the exit from the
high-pressure funnel to the accident
low-pressure funnel or offset right so
this is going to help us to avoid
contamination of neutrals right and
using the two funnels the high person
low-pressure is actually going to allow
us to deal with that increased volume of
gas coming through pump it down without
negatively impacting the lifetime of the
pump but then after it it goes through
the iron funnel well let me just say
that I always think it's interesting
think you know the iron funnel I think
about hurting people right and if we
look a little more closely that's really
exactly what it's doing right we had
these RF voltages which are focusing our
ions of interest into the center and we
have a DC voltage which is actually sort
of forcing them out down through the
funnel so what we're left with is this
focused beam of highly concentrated ions
with gas and neutrals and all that
hopefully not making it through not
being focused right finally we know that
most of these times were doing ms/ms and
most of what I've talked about is
optimizing generating parent ions but
there's also a daughter ion we need to
measure right and so there's ways to
optimize how many of the daughter ions
you're generating and actually
transmitting down through the mass
spectrometer right so this is 495 it's
going to use this this curved hexa pole
collision cell and it's it's tapered so
you have it a little higher at the
beginning so that more gets through and
then they get focused and and
transferred transferred down so I would
be lying if I said I understood all of
the improvements that go into this but
at least I wanted to try to understand
whether I was being sold a load of goods
or whether there was actually some
science behind these these improvements
so is there any science behind this
right so what can we do with this sort
of 6495 instrument so this is the
testosterone method which we've
developed in my lab here we're going to
be working with is 100 microliters of
plasma or serum we incubate with our
c-13 internal standard for my sciences
and then after an incubation step we add
3 micro liter massotherapy to either
resuspend mix dry it down we're able to
concentrate here by Risa spending with
hundred microliters of mobile phase and
then we're going to inject now I
mentioned here that my chromatography is
much larger much much longer all right
so I'm looking at nine and a half minute
run to run but that's based on other
considerations I can definitely shorten
that and I'm using methanol instead of a
seasoned nitrile right but still
sticking with that that's C 18 column
and you can see my Kuan qualifier I am
therefore testosteron coming out at
about 5.1 minutes so how does this assay
perform so we compared ourselves to a
reference laboratory this is a Dean
Carlos method for measurement of
testosterone and estradiol where he has
also run those CBC host samples and you
can see at that low end below 40 we have
very good agreement with passing that
block slope of 1.06 r-squared greater
than 0.99 there were also three samples
which had below the one nanogram per
deciliter lower limit of quantitation so
that gives me confidence that
not picking up some interferences right
so where does this where does this leave
us
right so I think where it leaves us is
you really do have these options right
we can do accurate low-level
testosterone method measurements but
something like a 64 95 and a little more
straightforward simpler sample handling
we could also do it on a 64 60 we just
need to maybe have a little more sample
prep involved right so what's going to
work better for your lab this was a nice
little survey I saw from chromatography
online where they were just asking
people how much time do you spend on the
different processes right and you know I
would contend that this is maybe under
estimating the time most of us spend on
data management is it about 27 percent
but you can see that the sample
processing 61% consumes the bulk of our
time I know in my laboratory
it is incredibly challenging to find
certified licensed technologists who are
able to work in the lab and do these
more advanced instrumentation methods
including some of the sample prep right
and so certainly when when I was
thinking about the methods I know either
one can work but I felt for me
personally in my lab being able to put
out that investment and have a slightly
better instrument is going to save me a
lot more in terms of the labor costs all
right but keep in mind both accomplish
the exact same assay you know low level
testosterone measurement it's just a
question of where your trade-offs are
where your pain points are and I think
ultimately for me to thinking about what
next steps might be in my laboratory
right what is the next assay I'd like to
do expanding our testosterone assay to a
full steroid panel which might be more
possible on the higher level
instrument but I really don't think that
there is a right or wrong here it really
is just thinking about the sample prep
involved and whether that fits your lab
or whether you possibly need to consider
another direction and with that I'll be
happy to take any questions you might
have
thank you so much dr. Hayden for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of your presentation the window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen
and click the send button well answer as
many times as questions as you have time
for today so let's look at our audience
questions as they're coming in our first
question is is there a mid-level ms
instrument option yes so if I'm
understanding correctly the question is
and I'm just going to flip back in
slides is there something on the middle
of this curve you know if you if you
can't afford the highest level but
you're not convinced that you can do the
solid phase extraction the derivatives a
ssin and and the answer is absolutely
yes you know there there is a mid-level
instrument which we have we have them
that 60 or 70 sitting in our lab which
we use for for other techniques I've
certainly been thinking about looking at
what it would require for that
instrument to be able to to do
testosterone measurement you know can I
just do the liquid liquid extraction
doesn't look like that's necessarily
going to be an option but could I do
something like a straightforward SPE if
perhaps I wanted to save myself the
trivet is a ssin and looking like that
might be possible also exploring
different derivatives ations
but I would say there's definitely a
range of options you can use you just
have to be aware of what sort of sample
prep procedure is going to be necessary
and where's that trade-off between the
instrument performance and the amount of
sample prep involved
Thank You dr. Hayden here's our second
question what impact do you see on your
precision from extra sample prep
okay so what what impact does extra
sample frappe have on the precision of
the instrument right so my my general
Gestalt I guess I would say is that the
more you manipulate a sample the less
precision you have right so more steps
involved is more opportunity for
variable performance variable sample
loss so you know doing a three step
sample prep or multiple solid phase
extraction x' each one of those is going
to introduce variability and affect your
overall precision so I didn't talk about
that but I do believe that your
Precision's your CVS are going to be
helped by simpler sample prep giant
caveat there right two of them one is to
reiterate again sample prep helps keep
your instrument clean and cleaner
instruments perform better over the long
time and then second thing is robots
don't make mistakes right so if you are
automating your sample preparation as a
way of fixing this you know amount of
time spent on sample processing then
you're probably going to see very
minimal impact on your precision with
automation although you know I'm not
sure I have sufficient data to really
support that statement I just made but
in general robots are gonna have less
variability so I think you're going to
increase in precision with more sample
prep but you can mitigate that by having
automated sample prep Thank You dr.
Hayden and thank you to our audience
today for your participation wonderful
questions we have time for one more
question before we end dr. Hayden why
liquid extraction and not SPE in the
6495 method yes so why did we go with
the liquid liquid extraction so I think
that this is sort of in
interesting preference so I sort of
started I trained working in labs that
were very comfortable doing liquid
liquid extraction
I think it's relatively straightforward
I think there are ways for you to choose
the appropriate liquid liquid solvent to
do the extraction so you can get some of
that selectivity you might see with
cells phase extraction and you know as a
consequence of that I'm sort of fond of
liquid liquid extraction whereas I have
less experience with solid phase
extraction and you know the experience
I've I've had where you're working with
a positive pressure manifold or vacuum
manifold you know it works fine but it
has its own idiosyncrasies which I'm not
as familiar with now all this having
been said I know a number of people who
simply won't do liquid liquid extraction
and I think some of that probably has to
do with the volume so I've rarely worked
in a situation where I'm processing you
know two three plates a day and so
liquid liquid extraction is kind of
typically been a workflow option for me
although it is harder to automate liquid
liquid extraction there are sample
handlers that can absolutely pipette
organic solvents so the you know the
Hamiltons I think really I've seen them
excel at that just not say others can or
can't just that my experience has been
thing Hamilton's do it quite well but it
is definitely still harder and there's a
lot of considerations if you want to
automate your liquid liquid extraction
where solve is extractions a little
easier to automate so some people prefer
that I don't know I've certainly thought
about trying a solid phase extraction
for our testosteron even on C's 495 just
to see what it would look like and how
that workflow looks relatively le so I
know that doesn't really give you any
data-driven answer it's just to say it's
what I've done it's what I've seen it's
what I'm comfortable with so it's what
we did and it worked wonderful thank you
after Haven and thank you so much again
for your presentation I know that you
and Agilent Technologies
our sponsor are willing to take any
additional questions by email did you
want to have any closing remarks before
we close today you know certainly as you
said feel free to reach out with
questions you know I've learned so much
from speaking with other folks in the
field and just trying to learn from them
and you know I'm happy to share that or
maybe if you have a question it
highlights something that I myself don't
know well enough yet and so because for
me to find out the answer to it so yeah
definitely please feel free to reach out
and I'd like to once again thank you
again for your presentation and also
thank you lab roots and our sponsor
Agilent Technologies for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through February 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share of
an announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye